hey everyone simon liu here and i'm with
my fellow castmates aquafina and monger
from marvel studios shanxi and the
legend of the ten rings and today we're
gonna answer some rapid fire questions
you ready let's do this here we go
fun dangerous frisky fierce kick a lot
of
oh sorry that's too many words
i can move my ears
i eat a lot that count right i can walk
into a room and say something about my
acid reflux and everyone slowly leaves
okay
bungee jumping skydiving i've always
wanted to jump into a split when no one
was expecting it like
like in walgreens you know and it's like
oh oh i could i could do something what
are you talking about
they play a big role in the origin story
of iron man and now you're gonna see how
it factors into this character chongqing
it's so heartwarming and so much love
it is going to show you a part of the
mcu that we have never explored
action sequences like you have never
seen before
don't miss it don't miss don't miss
marvel studios shangqi and the legend of
the ten rings
go see the movie